Okay, so let's get started with today's
lecture. So as you remember on Monday,
we looked at the optimal control problem
through a closed loop lens
whereby the object we want to optimize
over is a closed loop policy. And we
introduced the most fundamental
algorithm that we have at our disposal
to compute closed loop optimal policies
which is referred to as dynamic
programming. We derived the algorithm
for a discrete time formulation of the
problem. We will actually extend this
derivation to continuous time next week
which will lead us to the Hamto Yakovi
Bman equation and reachability theory.
And to do so we discuss uh some
structure some key structure that the
problem the optimal control optimal
control problem as we formulate it has
that we can leverage to derive dynamic
programming equations and then I
presented LQR as one example that allow
me to show you how to apply the dynamic
programming uh recussion
and at the same time LQR is a problem
that is of interest in its own right now
in the second P set you have a number of
opportunities to strengthen your
familiarity with dynamic programming and
LQR. You'll have one exercise that shows
how much computation you save by running
dynamic programming as a solution
algorithm as opposed to brute force. You
will have uh one exercise that uh forces
you to implement from scratch from
scratch an LQR algorithm.
I know that you could use an AI agent to
do so but at least for once in your life
try to do it uh uh from scratch and then
we'll transition into the material that
we're going to discuss today
specifically
we talked about LQR at the end of the
last lecture today rather than
introducing a new concepts in optimal
control we are actually going to um
spend the entire lecture on how we can
leverage LQR in a variety of different
control settings. As as I said, LQR is a
formulation that is of interest in its
own right. What we use in the field of
controls and robotics and beyond. So I'm
going to dig a little bit deeper on how
you can use LQR as part of the control
loop. Then next week we'll generalize
the formulation to a stoastic
formulation. So we'll assume the
dynamics are perturbed by stoastic
disturbances. That would lead us to the
stochastic version of dynamic
programming equations that you might be
already familiar with if you have taken
a class decision making and uncertainty.
And then uh uh next Wednesday we will
cover the continuous time
uh formulation of closed loop optimal
control which will lead us to the
extension of the dummy programming
algorithms in continuous time referred
to as the harington Jakobi Bman
equation. After that we'll then move to
MPC just to give you an idea about where
we're going.
So as I said today we're going to focus
on LQR style algorithms for optimal
control. I would claim that after P
control LQR is the most widely control
uh theoretical algorithm used out there.
So it's very important for you to
familiarize with the concept
particularly LQR as we set it up.
We set it up with a goal of finding a
control that drives the state to the
origin. That's why it's referred to as a
linear qualatic regulator. The goal is
to do regulation to drive the state to
the origin. But in general in especially
robotic system, you're not that
interested in driving the state to the
origin. You want to drive the state
toward a desired behavior or a desired
trajectory. Can we still do that with
LQR? And the answer is yes. And we look
at how to use LQR in this setting by
looking at uh LQR as a mechanism to do
trajectory tracking both in a linear
setting and in a linear setting.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi.
>> You said that this is the most common
outside of P. I was wondering if you
could talk maybe for like 30 seconds or
so why you would choose this over P and
>> well the the problem with P is that you
don't really have a notion of an
objective function in LQR you can more
intentionally specify your objectives
there are indirect ways to shape the
response of your system with P
controllers and if you're taking a class
like engineering 105 or 205 you spend
quite a bit of time in terms of mapping
relationships between phase margin
engage mark margin or placement of poles
with rise time and so on but it's a bit
indirect with LQR you have a very uh
explicit uh uh handle on how to optimize
operations but on top of it LQR as we
will see today is very flexible it can
be used not just for stabilization
purposes but also for trajectory
tracking purpose purposes and even as a
tool to compute trajectories
uh for optimal control problems
>> you say that it's been better unless
to implement um
>> I think it's very complimentary so
typically P is used as the last step of
your control hierarchy when you really
have to manipulate the signals that go
into the actuators literally throttles
[snorts]
steering
opening valves and such. LQR is sits
just above P A's more about uh
trajectories.
So don't view them as in opposition to
each other. They're very much
complimentary and by the end of this
class we'll have a bit more of a
discussion about how you bring all these
tools together. Typically the way that
uh a decision making
um logic is uh architected is that you
have typically p at the end of the day
at the lowest level. Then you have some
trajectory optimizer which could be LQR
derived. It could be SCP it could be
some other direct method. On top of it
you still have to set objectives. So how
do you do that? You can use uh
techniques from uh decision making.
These days maybe you may want to use
more datadriven techniques. You can use
large language models, vision language
models. And the difference between these
layers is essentially the granularity at
which the physical knowledge and
physical properties of the system are um
leveraged. Typically at the level of
decision making, you don't really reason
about all the nuance aspect of your
dynamics. Like for example in your brain
if you want to set the goal of moving to
that door you don't really reason about
all the joint displacement in your arms
and so on. When you start you know
optimizing for your trajectory probably
you take into account that you are a
dynamical system you need to have some
space around you but still you're not
thinking about all the joint level then
what then you start going down the
control. Does it make sense?
Yeah. Very good question. All right. So
as I said, we're going to look at LQR as
an algorithm to
um uh derive tracking algorithms also as
a way to devise a new way to compute
trajectories for optimal control
problems which sounds a bit weird. So we
derive LQR as a solution of optimal
control problem in a very specific
setting of linear dynamics and quality
cost. We'll see how that then can be
used as a way to derive a new direct
methods for optimal control. It's a bit
confusing but we'll get there. And then
we'll look at at this algorithm referred
to as iterative LQR quite popular. And
then we're going to look at the
refinement of iterative LQR referred to
as differential dynamic programming. All
of this is rooted in LQR ideas. Now some
of the equations will be will get a
little bit convoluted
for algebraic purposes. There's nothing
particularly complicated here. So we I
won't be printing all of the update
equations for the different matrices and
gains and so on. Everything is
explicitly provided in the uh lecture
notes that are referenced in this slide
and are also referenced in the syllabus.
All right. So let's get started. So
first of all a recap about LQR. LQR is a
very specific class of an optimal
control problem where we don't have
constraints on the state. We don't have
constraints on the control. The dynamics
are linear.
SK equal AX K plus B kuk. Note that the
dynamics are not necessarily time
invariant. Actually the mat the state
matrix A and B can depend on time as
denoted by the subscript K. This will
become relevant later. Well, actually
this is a useful property of MQR. And
then we assume that we have a quadratic
cost. So last time we looked at uh the
cost until here. So we have a quadratic
penalty on the terminal state plus a
running cost that entails a penalty
quadratic penalty on the state and
quadratic penalty on the control. You
can generalize this cost and change that
changes nothing in terms of our
derivations by also including cross
terms x * u.
Why would you like to include this uh
cross term into the cost function? Well,
maybe in some situations the amount to
which you want to penalize the control
effort might depend on the state you're
in.
But more mechanically when we'll be
using uh LQR as a mechanism to deise
uh tracking control algorithms that will
entail performing some linearization. So
these additional cross terms will pop up
in the cost function. So that's why I
want to present the equation this
slightly more generalized form. You can
write the cost function here a bit more
compactly in matrix form. You have the
quadratic uh term on the state xrpose qx
quadratic on the controls uranspose ru
and then you have the cross terms x hu u
hx that sum together and give you the
equation at the top. So the Bman
equation as usual entails minimizing
over the controller time K the current
stage cost plus the cost to go and we
know that in a QR the cost to go is also
quadratic. specifically if you do the
derivation same as last time.
So you start from the boundary condition
which is um a quadratic
because of how we set up the terminal
cost and then you go one step later you
set the gradient equal to zero. Then you
you solve for the control and [snorts]
then you plug that you plug that back
into the right hand side of the B
equation. You see that the cost is also
quadratic. This it stays exactly the
same. So the addition of the cross term
doesn't change anything. So you will
find that the optimal control law is
still a linear feedback in control. So
it's a matrix time state and the optimal
cost is a quadratic in the state.
The of course uh L and P update
equations will change slightly because
now we have a cluster details of which
are in the lecture notes. Not important
here to show the exact equations.
You can generalize this formulation even
further
by now introducing
uh not only cross terms but also um
linear terms in the state and in the
control and also constant terms. So now
you have a cost function that is quad in
the state quad and control linear in the
state linear and control plus a constant
term.
The main reason why we interested in
this kind of generalization is because
when we are going to use LQR for
tracking purposes and you perform
linearizations, you have these
additional terms that pop up and you can
even for LQR generalize the dynamics. So
looking at a setting whereby x k + 1
is equal to a k x k plus b k u k plus a
d k.
So now the dynamics are no longer
linear. They're referred to as upfine
because you have a constant forcing
term. Think of this term perhaps a
disturbance like for example a wind gust
that we know will happen at time k.
Well, you can do exactly the same
derivation we did for standard LQR. So,
we write down the Bellman equation. We
start from the final condition
uh which is now a quadratic plus linear
plus constant terms. We set the gradient
equal to zero. We solve for u. Then we
plug that back into the right hand side
of the Bman equation. So what you'll
find is that the optimal control policy
is
uh a linear feedback term plus a feed
forward term and the cost function is a
quadratic that also has linear terms and
constant terms. Yeah.
>> So the equation we were using for
recapping that we're minimizing was
slightly different than the one you
talked about in last lecture.
>> Yeah. So here the main difference is
that I'm adding this cross term and my
main point is that when you do the
derivation the structure of the control
law and the optimal cost does not
change. You still have linear freedom
from the state and quadratic cost. Of
course the gain and the P are going to
change slightly
>> but also the instead of using Q and you
you had the H was there instead like
switch like your terminal state was
using H instead of Q. Did I change
terminology?
>> So you're saying that here I had an
>> H. And then there was no H though when
you were summing it. So it made it seem
like it was a completely different um a
different matrix that you were
multiplying against. Does that
>> here instead of QN we had what?
>> Okay. But it's fine. That's just a
terminology.
>> Yeah. Okay. But then there wasn't any
for there but there is not this term was
>> yeah 100%. So what I'm saying is that
what we had last time was everything up
to here.
>> Yeah. Um but this Q is from the is also
like that matrix
>> not overindex too much the symbol. This
is just any
matrix that you choose.
>> Okay.
>> I couldn't call it like side not matrix.
I couldn't call it double.
>> Okay. So don't think of it as the same
key.
>> Okay. This is just a generic uh matrix
that you choose as a designer. So the
deal with SQR is that once you set up
the problem then everything is procedure
you automatically get the optimal policy
the optimal cost. Now the baron of you
is not to solve the optimal problem is
to set it up. So your bargain is to pick
R to pick Q to pick H and to pick QN and
this is not always uh obvious. So there
is this is so called LQR tuning. It
takes quite a bit actually to pick these
um
uh parameters in such a way that you get
your desired uh response. Like for
example when I was tuning the LQRbased
actually tracking algorithm for you know
the invid program took about two three
months to actually get exactly the
parameters that you really want so that
you shape the right lateral response and
longitudinal response. You want it to be
of course safe but also you want it to
be very pleasant for a user. So there is
a little bit of an art and uh a little
bit of of course you can use simulation
to do that and so on and so forth. But
the point being those matrices are just
placeholder
um symbols that you should then select
as a designer.
Even further as I said here we are
adding additional terms. So we have the
CK that is something that you will pick
as a designer. We have this vectors QK.
This is something that you could pick as
a designer or as we will see when we do
tracking they are derived from a
linearization process. But the main
point here is that in this more general
setup the idea the derivation is exactly
the same. Actually you may want to try
to do it by yourself.
And what you will get is that the
optimal control policy now is a little
bit different. So
I still entail linear feedback on the
state.
For example, to your point, this thing
here in the previous lecture was called
FK.
So yeah, sorry for the mix up. LK XK
plus LK.
So we have a linear feedback on the
state. This is also what we had in the
most basic version of LQR. But now we
have a feed forward term. So a constant
game
and actually there is a very intuitive
interpretation of this control law
structure. I'll come back to that later.
And likewise now the optimal cost is no
longer just xrpose p uh x also has a
linear terms in x and then a constant.
All these uh values PK uh matrix PK
vector PK constant PK LK capital LK and
so on are all derived through Ricati
like equations update equations the
specific implementation of which is
provided in notes that are a little bit
cumbersome not super useful to show
here.
So bottom line is that LQR can be
generalized somewhat to cost where you
also have linear terms, constant terms
and cross penalty terms and to dynamics
that are a fine and the structure of the
optimal control policy stays either the
same or very similar mod of the addition
of a fit forward term and also the
structure of the optimal cost stay
essentially the same mod the addition of
some linear terms and constant terms.
That's it. Let's get to the interesting
part here.
So as as I said last time, we look at QR
as a a mechanism to find controls that
allow us to regulate the state of the
origin.
But in general, we're interested in
um
more general settings whereby we're
given some reference trajectory xar 0,
xar one,
xar 2
and so on.
So we have the reference trajectory xar0
xar one xar n minus one actually xn
and then u bar zero u bar one u bar n
minus one of course the control
trajectory and the state trajectory are
not independent of each other are linked
through the system equations x is
derived through the application of U
through the system equations. Where is
this reference trajectory coming from?
Maybe from one of the direct methods we
covered last time. So for example, you
run SCP on your general nonlinear
optimal control problem, you computed
um a trajectory in open loop form
and that's a trajectory that you would
like to follow.
But now the problem is that uh in real
life you have model mismatches. You have
a disturbances.
So uh maybe you may not start uh exactly
at xar zero. Maybe you start here. Maybe
there is some disturbance that brings
you here. So the question is uh
how do we find a control U that brings
the actual trajectory as close as
possible to the desired precomputed
trajectory. That's a problem of
trajectory tracking. Specifically we
want to find
a sequence of controls.
I put empty bracket here to mean that we
want to find a full sequence of
controls. U0, U1, U2 all the way to U N
one.
Um, somewhat close and I will be more
specific later somewhat close
to
the nominal
control sequence because that's the one
that we would like to track. We want to
track both the state trajectory and the
control trajectory
such that
the tracking error defined as the
difference between the realized
trajectory the trajectory
goes through and
the desired trajectory. So the sequence
of states you would have liked to go
through as specified by the precomputed
trajectory
is
minimized.
Does this sound like a reasonable
problem?
You're given a nominal trajectory. You
want to find a sequence of controls that
bring you uh back to that u
um to that trajectory. So you want to so
this will be delta x1.
For some reason some disturbance moved
you here. So disturbance was unm modeled
when you computed your nominal
trajectory. Now you want to get back to
your nominal trajectory.
So what can you do?
Let's first look at the simplest
possible case.
Not too useful but it allows to scaffold
intuition whereby the underlying
dynamics are linear. So SK + 1 is equal
to A K X K plus BK UK.
Okay. So for now we assume the dynamics
are linear time.
Now the reference trajectory or nominal
trajectory or desired trajectory these
are all interchangeable terms
has to be a physible trajectory for your
system.
So your nominal trajectory also has to
satisfy xar k + one equal a k xar k plus
a bk
uk k.
Again
a reference trajectory is a feasible
trajectory for your system
for system.
So then let's just take instead of
reasoning in terms of absolute states or
absolute controls let's reason in terms
of deviation variable. So we take the
difference between these two equations.
What we get is that delta x k + one
equal a k delta x k plus bk
delta uk
where delta uk are the deviation
variables with respect to the control.
So they're defined as uk minus u bar k.
So then you can see how the problem of
tracking actually has been reformulated
as an LQR problem with respect to the
deviation variables. Why? Because our
objective is to bring delta x to zero.
Now we have a system that is purely
defined in terms of the delta x axis and
deviation variables. So now and we want
to bring delta x to zero. So now we can
see that the problem is to choose the
deviation variables deltaU such that
delta xis goes to zero. If that happens
it means that xk goes to xar k and so
you have satisfy your objective.
Of course when you
run your system you do not and this
sometimes a point of confusion. You do
not control your system directly with
your deviation variables. You have to go
back your the control that actually you
will inject in your system is equal to
UK
bar plus delta UK because you know that
once you use UK as your control then you
go back into the difference equation
you'll have that the the different the
in terms of uh deviation variables is
guaranteed to converge to zero if you
pick delta U such that delta X goes to
zero. But how do you pick delta usage
that delta x goals to zero?
You set up an auxiliary LQR problem
whereby you set up
a cost function
that is quadratic in the deviation
variables for the state and quadratic in
the deviation variables for the
controls. You pick R, Q and QM. These
are design parameters. And then you just
solve LQR with a Ricati equation. That
will give you the optimal delta UK
as um LK times delta XK
and then you have found your desired
sequence of controls to track your
trajectory.
Does this make sense?
So we started from a tracking problem
that a face value didn't have much uh
didn't look uh look quite different from
a regulation problem. But then by
reasoning in terms of deviation
variables we were able to reformulate
the tracking problem as a regulation
problem with respect to deviation
variables. We then do control
development in the space of deviation
variables. And to do that we formulate
an auxiliary LQR problem with cost also
defined with respect to deviation
variables. And once you have found that
the optimal
control law with respect to the
deviation variables, you go back to the
original control variables that are the
ones that you actually inject into your
system. And then you guarantee that with
this choice
the deviation variable sets will go to
zero simply by pling the definition of
delta u into the equations.
Does it make sense?
So look at uh now the structure of your
control.
So now the structure of your
tracking controller has a feed forward
term that is your nominal control.
Of course if your state is exactly equal
to your desired state. this term is
zero. It means that you are on the
nominal trajectory. So you should indeed
use the nominal control. That's a sanity
check. That makes sense. [snorts] But
look at the structure. So we have a feed
forward term which is your nominal
control plus
a feedback term that depending on how
far the actual state is from the
reference state, it pushes you back into
your reference trajectory mediated
through this gate. So it's an openloop
term plus a closed loop term.
So this structure is actually widely
used in controls and robotics. This is
referred to as a two-step design
whereby the idea is that you first use
techniques from openloop control to find
your nominal trajectory and then you use
uh techniques for closed loop control to
find a controller that locally tries to
push you back onto your desired um uh
trajectory. Why is this useful? It tries
to balance the two um competing
considerations. On the one hand, you
want the computational efficiency of
reason in terms of openloop
trajectories, but at the same time, you
want to have the robustness that comes
from closed loop control. And here how
everything is coming together. You use
the techniques from last week to compute
these objects and then the techniques
from this week to compute a closed loop
controller. Of course, you could solve
the optimal control problem in closed
loop globally, but that would be
extremely timeconuming and perhaps not
even useful. Why is not even useful? And
then I will get back to your questions
because right now the formulation that
we have looked at is static. So the
constraints are given and so on.
But for a robotics application for
example, the environment is dynamic. So
I have now the current situation of this
room. I climb my path but maybe one of
your colleagues stands up and now my
constraint set changes because I also
have a new additional collision
constraint that I don't want to bump in
into the C like if she you know stands
up which means that in general you have
to reformulate this problem and
recompute the solution to this problem
periodically in time. So solving for a
closed loop control law that applies
globally for all possible state of the
words may even be wasteful because in
case you know that you'll never reach a
state that is very far enough from where
you are before you have to recmp compute
anyway uh your problem does it make
sense all question
>> is the gang term there is that constant
or does that also change
>> no this is a con well is constant but
the subscript k here means that it
depends on the stage so it's a time
value of course if you change uh the
formulation of the lure problem would
change but otherwise no lk does not
change is not a function of the state is
a purely constant game matrix given the
current stage
>> yeah uh just a clarifying so we get
[clears throat] the bars from like let's
say we did
or something like that.
>> Um, and then you reformulated by getting
the delta where I guess I'm a little bit
confused where when you got the delta of
the UK, now you know UK and you know the
bar.
>> No, you don't know UK.
>> This is just a definition of change of
variable. This is you know it.
>> This is you do not know it.
>> You just solve for data though. And once
you actually written about the delta U
and you assign a value to delta U then
you can
>> the time varying
>> that's right. Yep.
So this seems reasonable on the other
hand all of this was derived under
assumption of linear dynamics.
A more interesting setting is a setting
where you have a nonlinear dynamical
system. So how do you do tracking when
now the uh dynamics are nonlinear? Turns
out that uh we use essentially the same
techniques we have just
uh discussed. So specifically let's
assume that now our system dynamics are
nonlinear. So xk + 1 is equal f of xk
uk. Let's assume as before we're given a
reference trajectory again computed
through uh a direct methods for example
through SCP. Now the question again is
to find a sequence of controls U that
bring your state trajectory and also
control trajectory as close as possible
to their nominal counterparts.
On the other hand though now the
dynamics are no longer
linear. So we have
we have that your system dynamics obey
SK + 1 equal of X K U K and then you
have that your nominal trajectory which
has to be physible trajectory satisfies
SK + 1 equal F of X K
U UK dot
Can we still reformulate the tracking
problem in the deviation variables?
Yes, if you apply the following uh
trick.
So,
SK + 1
minus XAR
K + 1 is equal to F of X
U K minus F of Xar K UR K.
But now
let's do the usual trick.
So let's do a tailor expansion whereby
we approximate f around its argument x
and u evaluated at xar and u bar. So if
you do so
then we can write f of x u as f of xar k
comma u bar k
plus gradient of f with respect to x
time x k - xr k plus gradient of f with
respect to u multiply the u k minus u
bar k
jacobians. Yeah.
So let's call
um this derivatives as a k. Let's call
these derivatives as
bk.
So once we plug this formulation in
here, what we get?
is s + one minus xar k. So I'm just
substituting in here the line
approximation of fx fx and u. So what we
get this is equal to f [snorts] xar k
comma u bar k plus a k x k - xar k plus
bk
u k minus u bar k
minus f of xar k u bar k. So these two
terms cancel out. We define as before
the deviation variable as
x k minus x bar k. So this is the
deviation variable for s uh x of k +
one. This is the deviation variable for
u. This is the deviation variable for x
>> when you sorry.
That's right.
>> No.
>> Yes. Well, so this is a tracking
problem. So typically you start very
close to the initial condition that you
use in order to get your nominal
trajectory and the idea of a tracking
algorithm is actually to stay close to
your tracking uh uh to your nominal
trajectory. So in that sense the problem
is such that you want to stay close to
that nominal trajectory which means that
the linearization typically is a good
approximation because you're close
enough. But it's true there's always a
danger that you are deviating a bit too
much in which case the linearization
becomes useless and uh this algorithm
you know could become erratic. In
practice, it works quite well. But yeah,
it's a very valid point.
But the main point here is that as you
saw,
if we just by this approximation that
the dynamics can be linearized, we are
back to the linear setting whereby the
dynamics for our deviation variables are
linear. Which means that again I can set
up an auxiliary LQR problems with
respect to the deltaU and delta X
variables,
find the optimal deltaU and then
backtrack the tracking algorithm, the
tracking control signal as U bar K plus
delta U K.
So once basically you do linearization,
you're back again into the setup we had
in the previous slide of linear
dynamics.
Something that I want to note here is
that these jacobians here are evaluated
at x k
uk
x k uk. You are linearizing essentially
around the nominal state. You should be
at time k type one in this example which
essentially means that these jacobians
are actually time dependent. that the
dependency stems from the fact that you
are linearizing at different stages with
respect to different points on the
trajectory.
Fortunately, LQR works for linear time
varant dramics. So, this is not a
problem here.
>> Yeah, absolutely. if you had a physical
trajectory
what happens is that you're again a
robotic system you're moving around in
your environment and new stuff happens
so you compute a new openloop trajectory
so that's why in some settings you
cannot really premputee the inize the
jacobians but otherw if actually the
environment is static then absolutely
you can do that you can do that
>> yeah that's a great question So here
we're assuming that we know not just the
trajectory in the state variables but
also in the control uh variables. So in
that case you have so first of all for
some of the algorithms that we have used
they give you the full state control
pair in other settings and that becomes
a little bit more problem dependent if
you are given a state trajectory you can
backtrack the controls that give rise to
that state through the dynamics for
example using techniques from uh
differential flatness. So bottom line is
either you use an algorithm that gives
you the state control pair or somehow
you have to uh backtrack the controls
that give you that uh state trajectory
otherwise you cannot really use this
formulation.
Okay,
so that's actually quite useful and
again note the very intuitive form of
your tracking
control sequence. A feed forward term
this is the nominal trae the nominal
control that you have to use plus
a term deltaU that because of LQR is
given by linear feedback on the state.
So is a closed loop wrapper around your
nominal trajectory. Very natural. So you
have your nominal trajectory, someone,
you know, pushes you and then you have a
little bit of a a control algorithm
brings you back to where you wanted to
go.
Let's go one step further.
Consider now the
nonlinear optimal control problem.
And interestingly, let's now uh pose the
question. Can we use LQR to um compute
an optimal openloop trajectory?
It's a bit weird because right now we're
talking about closed loop control
policy. So we are using techniques from
closed loop control to compute an
optimal openloop trajectory. So we'll
see why that is a good idea in a second.
But for now, the problem is as follows.
We go back to our general nonlinear
optimal control formulation. We want to
find an optimal state control trajectory
for it. Can we use LQR ideas to do so to
derive a new methodology to compute
trajectories for nonlinear systems?
And the idea here is very similar to
what we did for nonlinear tracking
but with a little bit of twist in the
interpretation. So specifically,
let's assume that now we're given a
physible nominal trajectory. This could
be any trajectory as long as it is
physible.
Now the idea is not that we want to find
a control that brings you
closer to the nominal trajectory, but
rather a control that deforms your
nominal trajectory into better
trajectory. So we want to get away from
the nominal trajectory hoping to find a
trajectory that has a lower cost.
So you're given
a trajectory here uh xar 0
xar 1 xar 2.
So before say that uh for some reason
you ended up at x1 you wanted to compute
a control that was bringing you back to
the nominal trajectory
in terms of the variables delta x.
Now what actually want to do is to find
controls that shift these way points
away
by quantity delta x1 a quantity delta x2
such that now
you have a new trajectory
with a cost c2
that when compared to cost c1
is lower.
So basically you want to perturb each
waypoint in such a way that you get a
new trajectory with lower cost.
So then the question is can we use LQR
techniques to
select this kind of perturbations in a
principal way. Yeah.
>> Question.
>> So if your I guess I'm curious how you
would get a C2 that's less than C1 if
you already had your nominal and
assuming that by the nominal optimal
So the nominal trajectory is a physible
trajectory with some cost of C1 but I'm
not making any claim of optimality for
it.
>> Oh,
>> so I now want to get to a new feasible
trajectory but hopefully with lower cost
>> we can use the previous methods to find
like an optimal trajectory and then the
original idea for your like tracking
convert. So what what situations would
mean uh in this case we would just not
have done that. So we have a feasible
nominal trajectory but we know it's not
optimal or something.
>> Well so the question is where is that uh
nominal trajectory is coming from for
tracking purposes. It might be coming
from SCP for example. Here I'm going to
derive a new method to come up with a
nominal trajectory and then you will use
a QR to track it. So that's a little bit
uh confusing part that you shouldn't be
tripped. That's right. So for now we're
shifting gears. We're not talking about
tracking. Now we're talking about
trajectory optimization.
Okay.
So the idea here
is very similar as before. We want to
reason in terms of deviation variables.
But now we want to pick these deviation
variables not to drive a delta x to zero
but to drive delta x in such a way that
we get a new way points that give rise
to a trajectory with lower cost.
So the idea as before is to consider
um a linearization of your dynamics so
that you still have
uh linear dynamics with respect to your
deviation variables delta x and delta u.
But now rather than um setting up an
auxiliary lqr problem where the goal is
to drive delta x to zero you consider
different cost. So the dynamics are the
same but the cost is different.
Specifically what you do is you take
you have the cost of your nominal
trajectory C bar X C XAR U bar K. This
is what okay
the cumulative cost would then be equal
to C1.
And then you have the cost of a general
state controller UK.
So then you can write C of X K
plus delta X K and C of U
in terms of the deviation variable only
by just using a tailor expansion up to
second order terms. So we are
approximating the cost of a trajectory
with respect to the nominal trajectory.
Let me explain this a bit more.
So see so the dynamics are already we
already had the dynamics in terms of
deviation variables through the
linearization of the dynamics f.
Now what I want to do is also to find a
approximation for the cost in a way that
can be used in a LQR like setting.
Specifically the cost cx uk can be is
equal to c of x k plus delta xk
comma u k plus delta uk with bars and
bars. Okay. Oops.
Simply
because remember that delta x is equal
to x - xar
and delta u is equal to u k minus u bar
k.
So this step should be obvious. Now I do
the approximation whereby C of XAR +
delta X U bar plus delta U is equal to C
of Xar K U bar K plus
um derivative of C with respect to X *
delta X
plus derivative of cos with respect to U
time delta U. So here subscript x means
that we're taking the derivative of the
cost function with respect to the x
variables. Subscript u means that we're
taking derivative of c with respect to
the u variables. double x means that
we're taking twice derivable derivatives
with respect to the x variables and x it
means that we take a cross derivatives
first with respect to x and then with
respect to u. Here we're just doing a
tailor expansion of the function cxu
around xbar u bar up to second order.
So then the idea is let's compute the
deviation variables deltaU
in such a way that the pair deltaU delta
plus second order terms
in such a way that the pair delta x
delta u
achieve an approximated cost that is
lower than the denominal cost. So going
back to this drawing here,
essentially we are considering
approximation of our cost function that
allow us to inform the direction along
which we want to deform our trajectory.
Does it make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> You were like regularizing it so that um
or regulating it so that the delta
becomes zero, right? the difference
between the tracking
>> and the
>> for tracking.
>> For tracking. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> For this one here, it seems like you're
like intentionally making the deviation
non zero. So like what's the parame like
bring to zero?
>> No, here you don't want to be in the
data zero.
>> Well, remember that this is no longer
the standard. This is the generalized
when you also has constant terms and you
have a cross terms. So that's why the
delta tax here are not necessarily going
to zero.
If if it was only
this term here and this term here then
yes the delta x then wouldn't picked to
go to zero because of course you are
penalizing them quadratically.
So the minimum will be when delta x is
equal to zero which
introduces also another consideration.
So before when we were setting up the
LQR the auxiliary LQR problem for
tracking purposes, you as a designer
picked the penalty Q and the penalty R.
Here the penalty Q the penalty R as well
as the other matrices are derived from
the approximation. So you say who cares?
But you do care because uh um um you
want this problem to be uh well
conditioned. For example, you want to
have a Q to be positive definite which
means that you may you may want to
regularize some of these parameters. But
we'll look at these tricks and the
considerations in a second.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's the idea that you're using
to like estimate what the new cost is
the way.
>> Yeah. But you do so in such a way that
the new cost is quadratic. So then you
can use LQR derivation to very quickly
uh derive the um solution for data.
Yeah.
>> So the crosser
Oh no no I was going to ask why there
wasn't two deltas. There is two deltas
in the cross.
>> That's right. So one here and then
there's two there.
>> Yeah, I see. Okay.
>> So then the g does this make sense? So
now we have uh a cost that rather than
encouraging the delta x to go to zero,
encouraging the delta x to be chosen in
such a way that uh um you get to
trajectory to a lower cost
that x equals 0 is not necessarily the
minimum for this cost.
Oh yeah.
Okay. So then what do you do?
You linearize your dynamics. You
quadratize your cost. You run LQR with
respect to the deviation variables
deltaU.
And then you have a bunch of you have a
sequence of controls UK plus delta UK
where the delta UK are the ones that are
computed through LQR.
So now what you do is you go back into
your dynamics
starting from an initial condition and
you propagate your dynamics forward to
to obtain the new trajectory
that becomes the new physible trajectory
that you use for your subsequent round
of optimization. So that's why this
algorithm referred to as iterative LQR.
You take a nominal trajectory in the
rise of dynamics quantitize your cost.
Compute the optimal deviation variables
deltaU.
Do that for all the stages. Then
integrate the dynamics forward to also
obtain the sequence of states
corresponding to the delta use that you
have just computed. This is a trajectory
that in general has a lower cost and use
that as a new trajectory around which
you want to repeat this business.
Now, of course,
there are a bunch of approximations that
are made here. So, I'll discuss later
when IQR actually may not work. But in
general, is the idea clear?
similar to tracking but just with the
opposite twist. You want to deform your
trajectory as opposed to go to your
trajectory. Now of course to your point
once you have computed through
iterations of this algorithm uh a
feasible trajectory that you're happy
with then you might set up an LQR
tracking algorithm toify it.
>> Yeah. So it's kind of like
reading the set. Are there like any
guarant?
>> No, not really because of approximations
that we're making with respics
which brings essentially
um
actually I'll get back to your question
in two slides.
So here to iterate iterative LQR
essentially comprises two steps a
backward pass and a forward pass. In the
backward pass we compute a locally
linear dynamics locally quadratic cost
around the nominal trajectory. We solve
uh the rec equation to compute the
optimal delegation variables deltaU.
And then in the forward pass we use the
optimal uh control policy UK plus deltaU
in order to obtain the state sequence.
Now something people sometimes uh get
wrong is when you do the forward
propagation of your dynamics, you don't
use your linear approximations. You just
you actually use your true dynamics sk
plus one if equal to f of x k uk since
you know your dynamics and forward
propagating dynamics is easy. There is
no reason to use an approximation there.
So you forward propagate with the exact
dynamics.
Oh I have it here. Propagate full non
dynamics f not the approximate dynamics
and it iterate until convergence. Like
for example, as usual, the cost
reduction after a few steps is
insignificant or the differences in uh
for example in in the state space amount
trajectory is insignificant then you
stop or maybe you have a maximum amount
of iterations as a budget.
So going back to what you know from last
week of course there are a lot of
commonalities with respect to SCP is
very similar. So you uh linearize your
dynamics
and you can convexify your cost but with
a few differences. So first of all in
SCP
you are using a convex solver to solve
the problem.
In IQR you use the LQR equations that
are almost anal they are actually
analytical.
So LQ IQR is easier to implement because
you're just implementing recatic
equations and then injects some
derivatives with SCP is a bit more
complex because you also have to
implement a convex programming solver.
So this seems that this seems to imply
that IQR is better than SCP. SCP though
is a bit more powerful. is more powerful
first because it doesn't require
necessarily
um a quadratic formulation of the cost
and your approximations. It could just
be a general convex approximation. But
most importantly, SCP allows you to
reason about control constraints and
state constraints as long as the problem
is convex
in IQR. In LQR, there are no
constraints. If you add constraints to
your problem formulation, all the
results related to the recarded equation
don't hold anymore.
So they are uh similar in spirit. They
rely on successive approximations, but
they also be different in terms of
complexity. SCP is a bit more complex,
but it's also a bit more general.
It's also a bit more SCPs also be more
difficult to implement. You have to
think about trust regions as we
discussed last week and so on. Um now
historically IQR was um one of the most
popular algorithms because you know
super easy to implement rec equations
plus someations. These days convex
programming solvers embedded comics
programming solvers have become so
powerful that even though you had to
solve an online optimization
uh through iterations is not too bad. So
SCP has also become a fairly popular
direct optimization algorithm. Yeah. So
you can really only use ILQR if you're
like not close to the limits on your
control or the limits on your state
because otherwise
>> there's no reason that your iterations
would go over the values.
>> Yep.
>> That's right. Yeah. So at you have to be
a bit careful in terms of how you handle
uh constraints. You can handle those
constraints a little bit um uh for
example you can add penalties into the
cost but you have to be a bit be careful
but you cannot handle the constraints uh
explicitly as constraints.
So going back to be a bit quick here. So
there are a number of considerations
that one has to consider to make IQR
work. First of all, as also your
colleague mentioned, you have to make
sure that the new state control stay
close to the linearization point.
Otherwise, all the approximations that
we made may not hold anymore and
actually trajectory that you compute
after one iteration might even have
larger cost
which brings us to the second bullet
point. So when we roll out the policy
forward in time sometimes you want to d
the tune uh the control such that you
don't get it too far from the iteration
from the trajectory was computed at the
previous iteration. So you may do a
little bit of line search in order to
find the uh the feed forward term that
keeps you close to the the previous uh
trajectory.
We need to decide an termination
criterion. We have already discussed
about this. Um
this is an iterative algorithm, a local
optimization algorithm. There's no
guarantee to get to an optimal uh
solution. So a good initialization is
critical.
These days a very powerful way of
initializing these u iterative solvers
SCPs, RQR is for example to use
datadriven techniques. So basically
neural networks that have seen a
gazillions of optimal control problems,
you just uh uh use the prediction from
that neural network as a warm start to
uh start these iterations. So you get
the best of both worlds, the generality
of datadriven control, but also the
asurances of um formal optimal control.
Cost matrices that may not be positive
definite when you do your linearization
or quadization. So you may want to
regularize them for example by adding a
constant plus the entity in order to
shift the spectrum.
In general, there is a great collection
of tips and tricks in the thesis of
Yuval Tasa and I refer you to section
2.2.3 if you if you had to implement an
IQR and you have a little bit of issues
with um tuning some of the parameters.
Now as a last topic and here will be
quite quick. I want to talk about
differential dynamic programming which
is essentially
a slightly more powerful way of
implementing IQR like ideas. At a high
level what DDP is doing is the
following. In IQR, what we do is to
locally approximate the dynamics of your
system around the uh nominal trajectory
and locally approximate the cost again
around the nominal trajectory.
But once you do that, then you're left
with an LQR like problem that you solve
exactly using the cut equations. In
differential dynamic programming what
you do is to approximate directly
the Bman equation.
Specifically
the idea of differential dynamic
programming is as follows.
So in RQR you approximate uh your
problem and then you run dummy
programming exactly in DDP you directly
approximate the dynamic programming
equation specifically you remember from
last time from yes uh yes last time that
the oper cost at stage K given state X
of K is equal to the minimum over U K of
C of x k
uk plus j k + 1 of f of x k uk.
So this is the Bman
um
is the Bman equation right?
So this is equal to
the minimum over
u k plus delta u k. Remember that the
delta u is u minus u bar where u bar is
a nominal control trajectory.
C of X K + delta X K U U K plus deltaU K
plus
JK + 1
[snorts]
of F of SK plus delta x k comma u k plus
delta uk.
So let's define the right hand side of
the Bman equation as a general function
Q of X K plus delta X K. Sorry, this
should be a bar and it should be bar
and it should be bar
comma U bar K plus delta UK.
So this function Q is referred to as a Q
function and will play crucial role when
we talk about the datadriven control but
for now we don't care about it.
So you see that this function uh is just
a function of xar plus delta x and so
this entire thing is a complicated
function of uh xar plus delta x and u
bar plus delta u.
Remember that in dynamic programming
jk + one has already been computed.
So this is a known quantity f we know
it. So we do know this uh function. We
know how to take derivatives. So the
idea of dynamic programming is to
locally quadratically approximate the
right hand side of the burman equation.
So
minimum over u bar. So this is just a
constant right this is a nominal
control. Minimum over u bar plus delta u
is equivalent of taking just a minimum
over delta u. We're optimizing over the
same set of numbers.
So if you just then approximate
q of xar plus del that x u bar plus
delta u quadratically.
Now we are just solving
a quad um equadic problems with respect
to delta use.
X is given XAR is given. So the only
variable is deltaU.
So how do we solve um we're just left
with a problem of computing the optimal
deltaU that minimizes the uh quadratic
approximation of the Q function
but this is super easy to do right you
just take the derivative equal to zero
do you see what I'm I'm doing here so in
dynamic programming we we are moving
backward in time. So this function is
known, this function is known. So
everything here is known. X is known
because you're fixing it in the dynamic
programming recussion. The only thing
that you're optimizing over are really
these deltaU variables.
Now what you do in this dynamic
programming is to take this very
complicated function and approximately
approximate it in tailor series up to
second order by using XAR and U bar as
your reference point for your
approximations. So that now this
optimization problem becomes a much
easier problem whereby you want to find
the delta use that optimize a quadratic
cost which is really the quadratic
approximation the Q function which is
written here is for the 10th time in
this lecture a second order
approximation of a function.
So how do I minimize this quadratic
function with resp to u I take the
derivative and set it equal to zero. So
the derivative of a Q whereas we do
deltaU u is this term is a constant.
This term is a constant. Here we have a
q u k
um this term is a constant. Here we have
a quadratic. So here we have a plus
q. Remember that the subscript u means
that this is jacobian with respect to u.
Q U U comma K of deltaU
plus.
So this is a linear term. So we take the
respect to delta U. So we get plus qxu
K times delta X. We set all of this
equal to zero.
And then we solve for the which is what
we have here. And then we solve for the
optimal deltaU.
And that's basically your
new control U K plus delta UK star.
So you plug this deltaU u back [snorts]
into the
uh
back into here. So what you get is a
solution for a Q in quadratic form which
means that now your optimal cost to go
is also a quadratic and then you go one
step backward.
So basically what you're doing in
dynamic uh differential dynamic
programming is to approximate the right
hand side of the Bman equation by
quadratizing the Q function solving for
the dotal deltaU whereas to the
quadratized version of the Q function
get the optimal delta U plug it back
into the cost function so that you have
actually a quadratic uh cost to go and
then go one step backward.
So here I'm writing down all the
derivatives of the Q function. Not too
useful to remember. The only thing that
I want to highlight here just to draw a
comparison with respect to IQR is that
if you go through all the derivations
you'll see that there are second order
derivatives for the dynamics. So
essentially differential dynamic
programming is a second order algorithm
in the sense it also uses second order
derivatives for the dynamics while in
LQR you only compute the first order
derivatives of your dynamics. So this is
a little more sophisticated algorithm
but in terms of uh uh in intuition is
relatively um similar. So we covered
quite a bit of material here as I said
next week we're going to cover the topic
of stoastic DP
but to recap so we have looked at how to
use LQR in a number of setting that are
to optimal control tracking algorithms
very important make sure that you're
familiar with that material we also see
we also saw how we can derive direct
methods for optimal control by
exploiting LQR
um results that led us to the ILQR
trajectory optimization algorithm and
then we saw a different way of doing
trajectory optimization that is still
inspired by IQR ideas but is a bit
difference in the sense that you
directly approximate the right hand side
of the Bman equation.
The results are very similar. You still
get controls that are a fit forward term
plus a linear feedback term. But of
course the gains are going to be
different here.
Bottom line, make sure that you
familiarize with IQR and with nonlinear
tracking with IQR.
All right, so see you on Monday.